well New York City has hired more than a
thousand so-called contract tracers
their job is to track the spread of
coronavirus they're expensive they're
being paid an annual salary of about 60
grand apiece that's five million dollars
from New York's taxpayers every month
the idea is that they're going to
prevent a second outbreak and therefore
a second lockdown in New York but
they're not even trying by the way the
concern from day one is that this new
force of employees would be used for
political purposes and they already are
tracers have been told not to ask
whether people infected with the corona
virus recently attended black lives
matter protests why is that for answers
we're joined tonight by Fox's medical
medical contributor dr. mark Siegel dr.
thanks for coming on what is this about
Tucker when it comes to public health
politician to undermine their
credibility by having different
standards for different people I'm going
to give you two examples tonight one you
already talked about first is social
distancing the other's contact tracing
social distancing governor Whitmer is a
huge proponent of social distancing
except when she went elbow to elbow with
the protesters and then one of the
representatives state representatives
from Grand Rapids said you know what
social distancing is critical unless you
have a great photo-op
here in New York State Governor Cuomo
uses the stick in the carrot this
morning he used the stick New York we
may lock you down again if you don't cut
it out this afternoon he used the carrot
places and we're in where he won't where
he'd mentioned up to 25 people can
gather the carrot and the stick now when
it comes to the contact tracing you're
talking about this is deeply disturbing
Tucker because contact tracing is at the
heart of Public Health but a
spokesperson for mayor de Blasio said
that the contact tracers here in the
city are not going to be proactive
proactive about whether you attended a
protest or not but the proactivity is
the very essence of contact tracing let
me give you an example down in Cape May
over the Memorial Day weekend there was
a party there was a super spreader there
the local public health officials zoomed
in and checked everybody in the party
they found out who had it who was
contacted by them they
isolated them and they prevented further
spread obviously that applies to the
protesters and obviously that's what New
York City contact tracers should be
doing being proactive and asking that
question where you win that crowd what
did you do in that crowd
who are you with in that crowd Tucker my
prescription for tonight instead of
politicians making these decisions why
don't we turn to physicians Tucker yeah
well that's that's the question you have
asked and we have seconded since the
very first day why not why not follow
the science dr. Siegel great to see you
tonight thank you thanks Tucker